so now i said [__] it i'm not gonna
steal no more
i'm gonna gamble
[Laughter]
because nobody gets hurt and i can pick
them
so i start gambling i'm winning but
my high school teacher was my bookie
he was my high school football running
back coach
and he had become a bookie he was always
a bookie i didn't [__] know this
so one day i'm talking to him and he
goes if you need to put a bet in
call me so i put a bunch of bets me and
stinky are putting some bets in putting
some bets in
and i get them up to like three thousand
dollars i'm 18.
i gotta rob somebody i had no family to
borrow three thousand dollars from
so i'm like what am i gonna do i said
[__] it we used to go to this jewelry
store
in west new york we were kids and we'd
go in there
they had no alarm on the door you know
those places where you go to the jewelry
store and for ah and you have to go in
hey they had no alarm on the door and b
that a bunch of old ladies working
so you go in there and you go i want to
see a ring for my girlfriend they give
you the ring and walk away
they give you not the ring the tray with
the [__] rings
and in some trays they had double the
ring
so i would lift the ring and put it in
my [__] shorts i did this for months
months i did this i would bring my
friends in there dog go get a ring
it's mother's day let's go get a ring
and every time he went in there
two old ladies and they'd walk away from
me take a ring
but in the middle of this thing and
there was two counters there was this
thing that you spun around
and on the top had thick jewelry chains
and on the bottom had bracelets
and i had a little wire connected to it
and every time i go in there i'd say
someday i'm going to take that [__]
thing
so now i get in trouble with this
football coach and i own the money my
buddy stinky calls me up and my buddy
marblehead
and he goes bro how are we going to pay
this guy go marblehead come get me
marlborough come stinky comes to get me
i go we're going to go rob this [__]
jewelry store but before i ask an
attorney buddy of mine i go if i get
caught
he goes it's grand larceny you get 10
years i said [__] it we ain't going to
get caught
we walk in there at 10 in the morning no
guns
no guns we walk in at 10 in the morning
i walk in first
the plan was there was a jewelry store
and there was in a vacant lot at the top
of the hill you had to run up the hill
you had to jump a fence went up the hill
that's where he put the getaway car i go
into the
jewelry store first marblehead's in the
car stinky's over here on deck
waiting to rob this joint i come in i go
and i got him i'm here to pick up a
piece
think of what's the name i tell him
whatever a sabbatino lady goes in the
back
i picked this [__] up and i
looked through the door because she had
a thing that she could lock it
and stinky opens the door so it can't be
locked i picked this [__] thing up i
run out
the plan was i was gonna run out and
since i'm a fast guy he was gonna jump
the fence
i was gonna throw the jewelry to him and
then i was gonna run around the corner
and meet him or
put in the trunk of the [__] car
we're 18 guys
a jewelry store with no gun
i didn't care i had to pay this guy to
two thousand dollars he was my teacher i
loved him
he smoked camel no filters and we used
to call him camel breath
because he had a mustache and it was
orange from the camel cigarette
so we used to call him camel breath
hysterical
so uh i throw the thing to him he runs
up the [__] hill i run around
i get to the top of the hill and there's
my man stinky with like four gold chains
i go dog where's the rest of the [__]
jewelry goes it fell
i go you better go get it and by that
time people coming out of their houses
because the the people put the siren on
and like what the [__] going on i'm
telling the people get back in your
house mind your business [__]
because this time i'm going for [__]
broke right or wrong it don't matter
i go over and start picking up jewelry i
start picking it up
i [__] run back you know me i'm a
cuban jew [__]
and i went to catholic school i'm the
worst kind of [__] jew you follow me
i got all the bases covered [__]
i put all the truth now listen i'm
sitting the back seat i can't even see
my feet
from all the jewelry all the gold chain
he said stinky's in the driver's seat
marble has
the [__] out of here i'll never forget
this we were trying to put the [__] in
the trunk
like that was the plan to put in the
trunk he couldn't get the trunk
open he couldn't pop it open it wouldn't
pop so there we are trying to put the
jewelry in
and we can't pop the [__] trunks go
[__] it get in the car we get in the car
we put on the fleet
we pull out and as we're pulling out
there's a red light
and there's a two-way road going this
way and that way there's a light
we pull up and austin a cop pulls up
with his lights on
he ain't looking at us but there was a
cop in front of him a car in front of
him
our [__] trunk mysteriously just
opens up you want to talk about [__] in
your [__] pants
i'm like oh my god guess what
we got away with it we went home we
chopped up the loot we lived like pimps
we were wearing gold chains that night
and [__]
we were out snorting coke we had like we
looked like mr t we didn't give a [__]
and we were greedy like people were
coming to us going we'll give you 20
grand we're like [__] you [__]
we're gonna sell it by the peace that's
how [__] puerto rican-ish we were
so if a chain said 1600 we cut it in
half and took 15
off 750 cash and that's what we did our
friend's parents would let us have gold
parties at their house
we'd go over there with black towels and
velvet and lay the gold down
[Applause]
i learned that [__] from let's make a
deal remember
that's how [__] crazy it was and
after about a week we're snorting blood
we're buying [__] we're going to eat
every night we're 18.
the world is [__] rich but i'm not
gonna use it
there's any black people i don't mean to
insult nobody that's just the word we
weren't [__] [__] rich
so this crime family in the neighborhood
they found out that we had robbed the
jewelry store
so they sent the guy that talked to us
at the bar and he's like how you guys
doing
you guys got balls we want to buy
everything for ten thousand dollars
what you got left we still had we had a
hundred thousand dollars worth of
jewelry
the guys like we you know we want to buy
from the ten thousand dollars i'm like
[__] you
we're not taking ten thousand we got a
hundred thousand here and we already
sold half
you know what they did they called the
cops on us
the mafia called the cause we wouldn't
deal with them but the cops went to the
high school looking for my name and [__]
they had me on camera but they had me
from the side
so they took my picture up there my vice
principal god bless the soul
was like coco they came up there looking
for you and i told them i didn't know
you
i mean hey oh yeah this i grew up in a
[__] badass high school
and how i knew was
i went i told the [__] mafia dude to
go [__] himself
like three days later a friend of mine
came with me he's like rage looking for
you he had a bar he was the vice
principal at school but he had a bar
so he goes he wants you to go up there
and see him so i go up there
i go to the bar with stinky in front of
me we going and he's like i got to talk
to you guys he goes here's the deal
the cops are looking for you they're
going to arrest you this week he goes
just get the [__] out of town i'll take
care of it this is my high school
[__] vice principal that's how cool
he was
so this is the story all right when you
rob something if they arrest you
yeah you go to jail but you have to pay
restitution i could tell you that i make
ten dollars a month i don't have to give
you as a dollar as long as i give you
something
could you imagine me owing you a hundred
thousand dollars but only have to give
you a dollar a week
i would have to pay you to saint
smidgeon's day the owner of the jewelry
store was connected so what he did was
he said [__] it don't arrest the guys
because then i won't get my insurance
money
because if they put the rest of this he
wouldn't have gotten insurance he
would've got restitution
so he took the insurance and they let us
[__] go i never got in trouble for it
now they can't arrest me it's been 25
years they could suck my dick